to yourself
[Music]
baby
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
i see them
american girls and american
guys we'll always stand up and salute
we'll always recognize
when we see old glory flying there's a
lot of men
dead so we can sleep in peace at night
when we lay down our heads
my daddy served in the army
we lost his right eye but he flew a flag
out in
our yard till the day that he died he
wanted my mother
my brother my sister and me to grow up
and live happy in the land of the free
now this nation that i love has fallen
under attack
a mighty sucker punch came flying in
from somewhere in the back
as soon as we could see it clearly
through our big black eye
man we lit up your world like the fourth
of july
[Music]
take off the sand put your name
[Music]
[Music]
red white and blue
[Music]
this big dog will fight when you rattle
his
cage
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm brought to you courtesy
of the red white and blue
[Music]
i paid my dues
time after time
[Music]
i've done my sentence
[Music]
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've made a few
my friends
[Music]
[Music]
we are the champions
[Music]
[Music]
i've taken my bout
and my gotten called
[Music]
no pleasure crew
i consider it a challenge
my friends
the champions
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
a celebration to laugh throughout the
years
so bring your good times
[Music]
[Applause]
let's all celebrate and have a good time
[Music]
it's time to come together
it's up to you what's your pleasure
[Music]
a celebration
let's celebrate there's a party going on
right
to here throughout the years so bring
your good times
[Music]
[Music]
it's time to come together
it's up to you what's your pleasure
it's a celebration
[Music]
it's a celebration
[Music]
let's celebrate
[Music]
let's celebrate it's all right
[Music]
[Music]
it's all right
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
not me it
[Music]
[Music]
i knew
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
potatoes
down
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
tell your children
misery in the house
[Music]
train
[Music]
tape
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she was more like a beauty queen from a
movie
she said i am the one
[Music]
[Music]
young
let me be careful
[Music]
she says
[Music]
just remember to always
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
cheese
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love to his tonic and gin
[Music]
[Applause]
but it's sad and it's sweet and i knew
it complete
when i was
[Music]
sing us a song tonight
[Music]
you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me my drinks for free
and he's quick with a joke or to light
up your smoke
but there's some place that he'd rather
[Music]
i need this is killing me as
a smile ran away from his face
well i'm sure that i could be a movie
star
if i could get out of this place
[Music]
is a real estate novelist
who never had time for a while
and he's talking with david who's still
in the navy
and probably will be
[Music]
and the waitress is practicing politics
as the businessmen slowly get stoned
yes they're sharing a drink for
loveliness
but it's better than drinking alone
[Music]
sing us the song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
it's a pretty good crowd for a saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cause he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see
to forget about life for a while
[Music]
and the microphone smells like a
[Music]
what are you doing here
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
do
ground control to major tom
[Music]
ground control to major tongue
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on
[Music]
check ignition and make god's love
this is ground control to major tom
you've really made the grace and
[Music]
this is made to come to ground control
i'm stepping through the door
and i'm floating in the most peculiar
[Music]
[Music]
is and there's nothing
i can do
[Music]
me
[Music]
um
tell my wife i love her very much
[Music]
there's something wrong can you hear me
can you hear me
can you hear me
[Music]
lansing michigan welcome the 45th
president of the united states
donald j trump
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that fight to me and i gladly
stand up
next to you and defend her still today
because there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that fight to me and i gladly
stand
up next to you and defend her
still today
i love this land
[Music]
[Music]
i know i'm free then i won't
forget the men who died who gave that
flight
to me and i glandly spend
next to you and defend
[Applause]
[Music]
god
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that fight to me and i gladly
stand up
next to you and remember still today
because there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas from
see the shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time
[Music]
i know i'm free and i won't forget
the men who died who gave that life to
me and i've had this end up
next to you and defend her still today
but there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless
[Music]
[Applause]
to be an american where at least i
know i'm free then i won't
forget the men who died who gave
up to you
and defend her still today
wow thank you very much thank you
i feel so guilty of waiting out here in
the rain they gave me a hat
i said you know they've been waiting out
here for hours i shouldn't put on a hat
right
they even said sir we have the cars
going to take you from the beautiful
air force one isn't that a beauty
but they're going to take you from air
force one i said i got to walk it i mean
these people are tough
they're from they're from lansing
they're from michigan i gotta walk it
i gotta walk it don't give me the
umbrella i'm soaking wet already uh
but hello lansing hello michigan this
was
the scene of a great victory remember
that four years ago donald trump has won
the state of michigan oh that was
big hadn't been done in decades but were
i don't know if you saw the poll just
came out we're up three in michigan
and i think we're up a lot more you know
they give you the fake polls i
i think we're up a lot more we're going
to have a great
red wave people that want to go out
and vote vote they want to go out and
they want to touch they want to vote
it's a great red wave it's happening in
florida we're up in florida
up four up four
you know i'm watching these guys the way
they talk to paul though
they're down 25 in michigan i said no
we're going to win michigan
no no i kid when i say 25 but they they
put numbers you know they're called
suppression
suppression balls they make you like
feel badly
so you say to your wife or you say to
your husband darling let's go out to
dinner and then we'll come back we love
our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real we're
leading almost everywhere
now i've got to say i'm working my ass
off here this is
this is sleepy joe the guy goes the guy
goes to his basement
he's he's got another lid you know he
goes to the basement the lid right
that's the garbage can they put a lid on
now yesterday we had three big ones
really big
in pennsylvania was incredible the
crowds were incredible like this they're
all
packed they got people outside i see
people on the streets
it's crazy
[Music]
i always say to my people why don't you
just get a bigger airport
get a bigger well these are better than
the arenas because you know
our rallies are bigger than they've ever
been and the arena has
even if it's 18 000 people we've had 40
45 50.
we you can't hold them and you know
what's nice you get out of the plane
you say a few words you go back to the
plane you say bye bye vote for me
but that's actually what democrats do
they say
they say vote for me and they're lovely
to you for a few months before the
election
and after the election it's they're gone
and nobody's done for michigan what i
have you have car plans being built all
over
and you didn't have a plan built in 42
years
you have them all over i tell japan i
tell germany now
no we're not interested go and build
plants and i always suggest michigan
because i have to tell you
i think of course i think of michigan
when i got the man of the year i got
man of the year in michigan a long time
ago like 12 years ago
nothing to do with politics they wrote
man of the i came here and i gave a big
lecture of the fact
i said mexico is stealing your plants
they're going to canada they're going
you lost 32
of your car production i said what the
hell is going on
it turned out to be quite a
controversial acceptance but i felt that
it's probably the number one reason that
i'm standing here because of trade
and have we turned that around
seven days from now we're going to win
the great state of michigan
and we're going to win four more years
in the white house and by the way
there has never been a campaign
there has never been a campaign in the
history of this country
first of all there's never been a
movement like this
but there's never been a campaign and we
had the record you know the record was
four years ago
that has had more enthusiasm or bigger
questions
don't forget they may have a crowd
that's a big crowd the night before
an election you know but not really
there's never been this is
thank you
thank you that's really nice
a phrase i really i say i don't think
they'll find it because look at all of
them back there look at them
look oh
hello john roberts he's been very nice
john roberts has been very nice to us
thank you john
but john there's never been a phrase we
love you in the history of politics i
don't care where you go
and it happens and i love you too i do i
love you too
but there's never been anything like
this in terms of enthusiasm in terms of
crowds
i saw obama this morning he had a couple
of cars there honking their heart
[Music]
and then i saw sleepy joe so he came out
yesterday right and you're going to see
this
he came out yesterday and he made a
speech and then they had to rip him off
the stage because
he had lost it because he's gone once
again michigan is going to answer the
call of history and show the world that
sleepy joe biden his dark money donors
and his corrupt special interests
and by the way there's never been
anything like this he goes into a
country
and the family walks out with billions
of dollars millions and millions
of dollars
[Applause]
and then the press isn't allowed to
report the press doesn't report it they
don't cover it
new york times washington post they
don't cover it
cnn you know i introduced the great
justice
of the supreme court last night right
they say it's the most important thing a
president can do i say maybe military
but regardless
we've rebuilt our military like nobody
would ever believe
but you know what it's one of the most
important especially because this turns
the court
they had a whole thing most important
thing in 50 years
and cnn and msdnc didn't cover
they didn't cover they wouldn't cover
they just couldn't even though the
ratings go through the roof
60 minutes had very good ratings the
other night a fake report but
the ratings go through the room but they
didn't cover my introduction
can you believe that my introduction of
a woman that's going to be there
hopefully for
50 years as far as i'm concerned
and last night we did we made history
and we confirmed
amy coney barrett to the united states
supreme court
and justice barrett will defend our
rights
we'll defend our liberties and our
god-given freedom
she's going to be fantastic and she's a
terrific person
joe biden kamala do you like kamala do
you like her to be your first president
if he gets elected three weeks into his
presidency they'll say kamala are you
ready let's go
that's why they're talking about the
that's why they talk about the 25th
amendment right three weeks three weeks
in joe's shot let's go calmly you're
ready
most liberal person in the senate
she makes bernie sanders look like a
serious conservative
this this will not be we can't let it
happen
this will not be the first woman
president you're going to have a woman
president
this will not be the first woman
president
that's a lot of cameras back here yeah
that's right
they're all they're all screaming vodka
you know ivanka you know she's great
she just loves she's out campaigning
today doing really well
but she could be very happy her
husband's here jared kushner is making
peace in the middle east
[Music]
where's jared where's jared we gotta
find him
you know he's never around too much he's
always sort of he doesn't want any
accolades but
he's done something nobody else has done
he's leading peace in the middle east
without blood
fine jared he doesn't want to be outside
he's missed her inside but he's smart
but ivanka she'd be very happy just
being at home with the kids that we got
are working
and you know who's making a speech today
first lady she's out in pennsylvania
she's out at pensa people love our first
lighting
our first lady's doing a great job
i mean she got the plague from china
so did i so did baron baron recovered in
about 12 minutes how you feeling baron
what was the problem baron i don't know
i didn't think i had a problem the
doctor told me
test it sir uh your sauna's tested
positive
i see him like 12 seconds later doctor
how's he doing he's
he's all better did you give him any
doctor do you give him one of those
miracle cures no sir he just recovered
hey
young kids have a very strong immune
system nobody even
knew it get your children
back to school get them back to school
i mean your governor's a disaster they
got to open up this
they're gonna open up this state
and she's gotta keep her husband away
from sailing and fishing
the only one that's free in your state
is her husband
no it's no good that's no good you can't
do it
joe biden kamala harris of course she
has it the
reverse you know she's got the indy
harris and he actually said it didn't he
in the harris biden you know i have a
great vice president and we all do
but and i want to give him tremendous
credit but i will never say
in the pence trump administration i i
will never say that but he says it
that's because he doesn't have any clue
where he is you saw that
and the radical democrats want to pack
the supreme court with far
left justices who will shred our
constitution
abolish the second amendment terminate
religious liberty
shield the violent criminals and
regulate your economy into oblivion you
will have a depression
if he gets in he's going to raise your
taxes at a level that nobody's ever seen
he is the first candidate i've ever seen
who is running
on a promise that i will
raise your taxes i've never heard that
one
i've been involved and followed and
studied politics for a long time he'll
be the first one
i will raise your taxes massively
this would be the biggest tax increase
in history i've never heard of that one
before i like running against that guy
this election
is a matter of economic survival for
michigan look what i've done we've all
done together for this state
this state you're building cars again
and if your union leaders weren't in the
pockets of the democrats because we get
the vote
but they got these guys that just you
know they come to the white house
they're so nice to me
nice to meet you but they go for the
democrats every time for
a certain reason someday we'll talk
about it but the people the workers are
for us and the workers are for me
biden's plan to abolish the entire u.s
oil industry you saw that
we'll [ __ ] our nation and send us
into a absolute deep depression
and you see what he did with frackie
there will be no fracking
there will be no he doesn't say it that
way because there will be no practice
there will be no fracking but he said it
for like a year
and then he got to pennsylvania where
we're leaving
but we're going to put it see that big
beautiful screen we'll have it up there
some it saves me a lot of words that
screen is great
it costs a fortune we only bring it to
very important locations like michigan
but then you can hear it in his own
words you don't say oh
the president's exaggerated now he said
no fracking no fracking no
then he goes to pennsylvania a million
jobs fracking
it's a big part of their economy big
part of your economy from the standpoint
of energy right and guessing
how do you like the gasoline prices at
two dollars right
it's amazing as they go up you produce
fewer and fewer cars well i got you down
to the lowest level you are so lucky i'm
president
i'm going to give another major tax cut
after already having passed the largest
tax cut in the history of our country
we're giving
a very big middle income tax cut joe
biden spent the last 47 years
outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders
and sacrificing american blood and
treasure in
endless ridiculous foreign wars
countries you've never even heard of for
the most part they're all coming back
you know that they've been coming back
but our soldiers are all coming back
we're all over the place we're all over
the place we're in places that even the
top people in the country have never
heard of these places
biden was a cheerleader for nafta you
you got
killed by them a catastrophe for the
auto industry and for your state
following nafta one third of the auto
jobs
left and they went to mexico and canada
but they went to mexico
biden enthusiastically voted for china's
entry into the world trade organization
fueling the rise of china on the backs
of michigan workers
what china has done there has been
nothing nothing nobody no country
there has been no country that has
ripped us
off for 25 years
30 years like china
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
flows into china and i put big fat
beautiful tariffs on china
we took in tens of billions of dollars
nobody else did it and you know when
they targeted our farmers i told the
farmers don't worry about it
we gave them 28 billion which is the
amount they were targeted
we don't have too many farmers in this
group we gave them 28 billion dollars
our farmers everybody's happy with that
you got about
three farmers here but you got a lot of
manufacturers remember when obama said
there'll be no more manufacturing
you'd need a magic wand well we had 700
000
manufacturing job you'd need a magic
wand
all together half of all auto
manufacturing jobs in michigan were
wiped out think of that
after the biden-backed nafta and china
disasters
china became powerful because of the
world trade organization it became
powerful
a terrible terrible thing for our
country and then biden goes around
saying well no china is good for us no
no no
they haven't been how have they been no
i don't think so good and then the
plague on top of everything else we got
the plague
sent in he repeatedly tried to slash
medicare and social security people
didn't even know
decade after decade minus twisted his
knife into the back
of michigan workers and workers all over
the united states
you don't have to take my word for it we
have joe on tape
please roll the tape
my problem is i voted for nafta i'm
supporting nafta
because i think it is a positive thing
to do and i do not pretend to be an
expert on
international trade matters trade
agreements like nafta and permanent
normal trade relations with china which
forced american workers
to compete against people making pennies
an
hour has resulted in the loss of 160 000
jobs
the president is absolutely right when
he says
that china has been cheating for 25
years and that bill clinton
didn't do enough about it george w bush
didn't do enough about it barack obama
didn't do enough about it rising china
is an incredibly positive development
for
not only china but the united states and
the rest of the world rising china
is a positive positive development it is
in our self-interest
that china continue to prosper we want
to see china rise
china is a great nation and we should
hope for the continued expansion
china is not our enemy we talk about
china
as our competitor we should be helping
the idea that china is
they're not bad folks folks china's not
a problem
allowing china into the world trade
organization which he supported
extending most favored nation status to
china which you supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us no do you think
in retrospect that you were naive about
china no
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the usmca is better
than nafta
it is better than nafta
never said i oppose frackie you said it
on tape
i did show the tape put it on your
website i'll put it on put it on the
website
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal
and fracking in a biden administration
no we would we would work it out we
would make sure it's eliminated
i guarantee we're going to end fossil
fuel
no more no no fracking i gradually move
away from
and i think it's critically important on
day one that we end
any fossil fuel leases on public lands
what about say stopping fracking and
stopping pipeline infrastructure
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking i have one final
would you close down or would you close
down the
other way i would transition from the
oil industry yes
oh transition it is a big in terms of
business
that's the biggest thing because
basically what he's saying is he is
going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas
i remember that pennsylvania oklahoma
let me ask you a question joe yeah
you're right here with me yeah
have you been on the floor of the senate
you were in the center for a few years
yeah
time and time again talking about the
necessity
with pride about cutting social security
cutting medicare cutting veterans
programs no you never said that no
when i argued that we should freeze
federal spending i
meant social security as well i meant
medicare and medicaid
i met man i'm at every single solitary
thing
in the government look here's the door
honest guy why don't you just tell the
truth here we all make mistakes
i am telling the truth and i not only
tried it once i tried it twice
i tried it the third time and i tried it
a fourth time joe let me repeat it again
i want
you just to be straight with the
american people
i am saying that you have been on the
floor of the senate
time and time again talking about
the need to cut social security
medicare and veterans programs is that
true or is that no it's not true
that is not true that is not true i'm
not veterans man i met
every single solitary thing in the
government
everything was on the table i did not
support any of those cuts
in social security or in veterans oh
whoa whoa
you everything was on the table all
right you're right you just said it
including in your judgment cuts the
social security and veterans in order to
get
the kinds of changes we need on other
things related
but we did not cut it i know because
people like me help stop that all that i
would say
to the american people go to youtube
it's all over the place
joe said it many many times i'm
surprised you know you can defend that
or change your mind on it but you can't
deny the reality
now to be fair maybe biden's not telling
us
because he's forgotten his own plans
watch biden's staff quickly swoop in to
shuffle him along
during a quickie escape the basement
trip to pennsylvania
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh barracks
i think that was terrifying
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george uh
georgia he uh gonna find ourselves in a
position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
look it's the whole thing is crazy is
that crazy
isn't that crazy craziest race
there's that craziest race
our country cannot be put in that
position
we have too much going too much
potential
we cannot be put in that position you
got to do what's right
because one thing we know president xi
of china
is not like that president putin
of russia has nobody been tougher than
russia nobody been tougher than me to
russia they want me to lose
so badly he's not like that kim jong-un
remember we're going to be in a war with
north korea what happened
what happened to the war kim jong-un
not like that they're top of the game
and most of the leaders top of the game
we can't have that we could say hey g
that's wonderful but we can't have that
we can't have that we have too much
potential
we're gonna have the greatest year ever
next year
we had the greatest year we've ever had
we had to stop it we learned about the
disease we saved 2 million lives
remember it was going to be 2.2 million
people were going to die
that was the model we saved 2 million
lives and now we understand we protect
our seniors
but we can't have that in 2016
michigan voted that's a lot of people
look at it as far as
you know i'm i'm hearing
i'm hearing the sound it sounds like
it's from 20 miles away
it almost is thank you
thank you in 2016 michigan voted to fire
this corrupt political establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally
putting america first we're putting it
first
and you know a lot of times because i've
become friendly with many of the
presidents and prime ministers kings and
queens dictators i must tell you
dictators
but i've become friendly with a lot of
them and they've
they say with two things it's incredible
what you've done with the economy they
always say that
they always say it no matter what they
say we have done the most incredible job
and they always start off by
congratulating me the next question is
they want to buy our military equipment
because we make the best equipment
anywhere in the world
and sadly with many of these nations who
are not that friendly
we have to say no does that make sense
does that make sense
anyway i don't sound like a politician
because i'm not a politician i never
wanted to be a politician
i became a politician for one very
specific reason
because we're doing a job in the history
of our country
in the first three and a half years
nobody has done
what we what we and this administration
has been able to do with regulations
with taxes with rebuilding our military
with
strengthening our borders by the way our
border the strongest it's ever been
we're building 10 miles a week the wall
is almost finished they don't want to
talk about the wall
remember that's all they talked about
was the wall the wall is never going to
get built it's never going to get built
then i got it built
it's almost completed they don't want to
talk about it and mexico is paying
for the wall remember that please if i
don't always play by the rules of
washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fight harder
than any president has ever fought
[Applause]
one of the biggest issues for michigan
as you know
is this race and in this whole thing
it's the race
it's all the subject of refugees and
what's happening with refugees and
where are they coming from biden is
pledged and you saw what happened the
other day in france
biden has pledged a 700
increase this was done in the manifesto
with bernie sanders crazy bernie he's
crazy
is he crazy or what but we love him
because we got a big pile of his people
last time with
and hillary and they're going to come
again because we're
we're right on trade one thing bernie
sanders understood our country was being
ripped off on trade
by our allies and our foes okay by
everybody
and he got it he couldn't do anything
about it but his people came over
large percentages of people they people
find that hard to believe
but they understood trade biden has
pledged
a 700 increase this is in conjunction
with crazy bernie and aoc plus
three who knows less about this stuff
than any human being on earth but she
does have a good line of crap
a 700 increase in refugees
from the most dangerous terror hot spots
on the planet including syria
somalia you know when i think of somalia
i think of
omar omar ilhan
ilhan omar who truly does not like our
country
you know we are going to win minnesota
because of
omar
because of omar she likes telling us
what we should do how we should run our
country isn't that nice
omar no we're going to win she hates our
country and we're going to win also
because
the national guard went in you must
should have been called a lot sooner
but the national guard went into
minneapolis
and it was a beautiful site it took what
22 minutes
it was over after a week and a half of
destroying minneapolis
so i think between ilhan omar
ilhan armar and
and really what happened with respect we
stopped it they should have called us a
week and a half early we're going to win
minnesota first time since think of that
first time i don't want to carry
on a guarantee i don't want to guarantee
anything i'm a little bit superstitious
but i want to tell you they like us they
like us in minnesota
and how to and how the hell she gets
elected i cannot understand it
his policies will turn michigan into a
refugee camp it's true
she goes i know you're right about that
who said that
right she just said i know
everybody knows he's also vowed to
terminate our national security travel
bans i got a travel ban
i said i want a ban i took a lot of heat
you remember that right at the beginning
because if it's okay with you i don't
want to have people that want to blow up
our country i don't want to have people
that want to kill our people
so we instituted a travel ban and it was
rejected by the first court rejected by
the second court ultimately it was
approved by the u.s supreme court
we have a travel ban and now if we have
countries that want to do harm to us
if we have people that want to do harm
we say
stay the hell out it's very easy
[Music]
and we're not going to open the
floodgates to radical
islamic terrorism we're not doing it
i've ended the influx of refugees from
terrorist regions you know that and i'm
keeping
the jihadists and the violent extremists
the hell out of our country if that's
okay now maybe you want them i don't
know maybe you want to
maybe michigan let's take a vote would
anybody like them to come to the
wonderful state of michigan
[Applause]
okay i thought i knew you pretty well
no it's you know it's not easy doing
this stuff and it's you know very
unpopular the people go after you but
you have to do it you have to do
ultimately
i do what's right and people understand
it people understand it
together we will continue to protect
american families
fight for american workers support
our police defend our second amendment
[Applause]
which has been under siege if i were not
your president you wouldn't have a
second amendment right now
secure our borders and ensure more
products
are proudly stamped with the beautiful
phrase
made in the usa
[Applause]
and by the way do i look soaking wet
because the media is going to get on
they're going to say he looked like hell
today
he didn't look good his hair was
terrible it was all
horrible he looked bad he looked bad
he looked like he was sweating does he
have a fever
no it's 32 degrees out here and it's
it's freezing and it's raining
and i'm just trying to keep up with the
tough
people of michigan that's all
see i was going to ask you permission to
put the hat on right
no no oh yeah yeah
[Applause]
that's a good hat it'll be on ebay
it'll be on ebay tonight
we will deliver record prosperity epic
job growth and a safe vaccine that
eradicates the virus and quickly ends
the pandemic
and we've done things that nobody
believed we could do
and the vaccines are coming right around
the corner and if i weren't here it
would have taken two three four years
before you had this stuff
it's happening now greatest companies in
the world doing it
normal life will fully resume and that's
what we want right
we want normal life normal life take us
back
take us back seven months ago we want
normal life
we had the greatest economy in the
history of our country that's what we
want normal life just think of it
that's all we want you know if we didn't
have the plague come in from
china it wasn't even going to be like we
had an election the only bad part is i
probably wouldn't be standing out here
in the freezing rain with you
i'd be home in the white house doing
whatever the hell i was doing
i wouldn't be out here and you know
we're going to two other great places
after this you know that right
this is stop number one i'll get off the
plane
at least you were the first stop because
i'll get off the plane and they'll say
he looks like hell what happened to what
happened to our president look at these
people
what happened to our president he looks
terrible
[Applause]
this election is a choice between a
trump super recovery or a biden
depression you're gonna have a
depression your 401ks
down the tubes look how great our soccer
had a little blip yesterday
because nancy pelosi will not approve
stimulus that's all
but it's a choice between a trump boom
or a
biden a lockdown but you're already
locked down i mean this thing
we got to get her going i don't know
we gotta get her going i don't think she
likes me too much
see i don't comment to that because
every time if i make just even a little
bit of a nod
they say the president led them on no
you i don't have to leave you
even a little nod they say the president
said right they asked me that question
in a crazy 60 minutes
wasn't she rude she just kept asking me
questions
and then they interviewed sleepy joe
when it was like everybody just fell
asleep
and they got great ratings that's
unfortunate they got such good ratings
that they'll want to do it again and
again
but now wasn't that terrible the
difference one is anger
craziness right fire coming out of her
eyes i look she sits down she said
are you prepared for tough questions i
said just be fair
just be fair no no i mean tough question
and that's
this is the way it starts with binders
hello mr vice president
how about did you see the reporters out
he was walking around with ice cream
right
what what flavor is it uh
i don't i don't know
no he knew he said he had vanilla
and i said i don't get see those killers
back there i don't get soft questions
like that
but you know i was being interviewed by
somebody i had a group of terrible
terrible people
sometimes i'll do an interview just to
see if it's so bad because i can do very
good
i can answer the question i take all the
smiling all the fun i just
boom boom boom nobody can do that boom
boom give him a perfect interview
and then i realized it's hopeless with
these people they just helped
us and i looked at him and we're in the
oval office i said you know
you're very unfair you're very dishonest
you're corrupt people
but you know what we're in the oval
office
i'm here and you're not right
[Applause]
i sent them on their way and then i read
the article the next day it was terrible
it was just
it bore no relationship to what i told
them but these are minor details
it's a shame you know if we had an
honest media this country
would come together so fast it's true
we have not all of them but they're some
of the most corrupt
people on earth they are so and you see
it
you see it with the biden corruption
they don't even want it they won't cover
it they won't talk about it
and that includes big tech section 230
section 2 does anybody know about
section 2
it's a choice between our plan to kill
the virus or biden's plan
to kill the american dream that's what
he wants to do what's the lock you all
up let's keep
let's stay locked up and you know so i
caught it
but i said hey i mean i was given
options i could have stayed in the
basement
of the white house for a year and a half
but i'm your president i can't do that i
can't do that
i can't stay in the basement of the
white house i can't stay in a beautiful
bedroom upstairs
for a year and a half of your president
and i'd go to meetings
and there'd be a lot of people at those
meetings and i'd say this
perhaps is dangerous i don't know this
perhaps and then one day
sir sir our great
white house physician white house doctor
he's here today sean where is sean is he
around he's
he's become more famous than i am white
house doctor
i saw so many doctors when i was in that
bed i said doctor i don't feel good
i had more great doctors more talent
than you've ever seen
they were lying around that i told the
story they're lying 12
12 doctors johns hopkins
uh all of them walter reed is so
incredible the medical
military hospital the doctors they
really are great but there were a lot of
them
i said i don't feel great doc i got to
be honest with you it's been a long time
but i don't feel great and they grabbed
me every one of them they grabbed
different parts of my body they all were
specialists
they were specialists and the bottom
line is i took something regeneron which
we're making available to everybody that
needs it free
and eli lilly makes something very
similar and we got we have things that
we didn't even know about think about
six months ago
and i don't know if it was the strength
of me i'd like to give me full credit i
don't want to give
no i don't want to give the drug i was
telling somebody the other day i don't
want to give the drug any credit
i want to say because i am a very young
person that's in perfect physical shame
i took that virus
and i woke up the next morning and i
felt like superman it's true
i wanted to get out of it i said doctors
get me the hell out of there get me out
but it's no great doctors but we know
things that we didn't know we didn't
know we had no idea about
much of the stuff and you see mortality
rate you see where that is now and
people go in you get better they say you
have immunity
that you can go in i could jump see this
crowd right here
i could jump right in i could give i
could give
every woman and every man i'd even kiss
the men
i could give every woman and every man
right here a kiss that i wouldn't catch
it i have a beauty
and until i came along you know you used
to hear you have immunity for life right
as soon as i had it and got better they
were not too happy about that
and they said the speed this guy got
better
but you know what as soon as i had it it
got better i said i had immunity it was
supposed to be for life
when it was me they said it's only good
for four months okay
okay anybody else's for life with trump
they said it's four months
so they brought it down now immunity
from life to four months
and you know now with them you can't
watch anything else turn on
kovid kovitkova kovy kovakov kovetkova
komen
komen we have a spike in cases do you
ever notice they don't use the word
death they use the word cases
cases like baron trump is a case he has
sniffles
he was sniffling one kleenex that's only
him one that was
it that he was better but he's the case
okay here's the case marrow job young
people cases and you know why we have so
many cases
because we test more so we go around
and they're a very by the way we're
testing very young people too we're
testing people in school we're testing
everybody
in many ways i hate it in many ways i
hate it we test everybody
and because of that now if i tested half
if i said
we are going to cut our testing down in
half
they'd go crazy because the cases would
go down
in approximately half right and then
we're going to cut it down in half once
again
and there are other countries that don't
do testing and they show very few cases
i mean it's a very simple thing
but overall it's good to have the
testing we find out where it is and
there are a lot of things but
they use it to make us look bad but
here's the story
it's kovit kovetkovan you can't watch
anything else
on november 4th you won't be hearing so
much about it
okay november 4. on november 4th you'll
hear
it's getting better it's getting better
you watch
no no they're doing heavy coven because
they want to scare people
and uh people people get it i'll tell
you they understand these people better
than
you are smarter than most of the
political people in this world you get
it
very smart no november 4th you'll see
there's a big difference and i'll tell
you what
you know what else is going to happen on
november 4th your governor
your governor at the urging of her
husband who has abused our sister very
badly
the only man allowed in the state of
michigan the only man allowed to go
sailing
is her husband now your governor i don't
think she likes me too much
[Music]
hey hey hey hey i'm the one it was our
people that
helped her out with her problem and
we'll have to see if it's a problem
right people are entitled to say maybe
it was a problem maybe
it was our people my people our people
that helped her out and then she blamed
me for it
she blamed me it was our people that
helped
i don't get i don't get it how did you
put her there
how did you put how's john james doing
good
he's good oh he said i didn't even know
he's your john
wow is that nice well i didn't even know
see i'm thinking about you and i don't
even know you're here john
i picked him out of a group of people
they all had loaded up with money john
had money successful
where he was really successful is in the
military he could pilot a helicopter
better than anybody i hear
[Applause]
and i said who the hell is that guy it's
true i saw john
i saw john
this is our that's in honor of john
[Applause]
no no no i but here's what happened real
quick i saw john i saw four people
a different position he's running for a
different thing he did great by the way
but i saw four rich guys
and i saw john and i said go back
the world's greatest invention right not
television tivo
because without tivo television is
useless
so i say who is that i don't know i
think his name's john james
i said do me a favor go back now the
other guys had a lot of money they were
spending a lot of money right
four i think four guys four guys i said
that guy
i'm pretty good at this stuff that guy
can be a star
right i called him i spoke to him
i endorsed him the four rich guys will
never talk to me again but that's okay
they were gonzo
that was the end of them and he ran a
phenomenal race
and now i'm hearing john that you're
actually leading
he's running against a guy peters
think of it john james is running
against a senator u.s senator that
nobody has ever heard of before
even in washington peters i said who the
hell
is peters he's the senator from michigan
nobody's ever heard of him
i'll tell you what if one thing comes
out of this small group of thousands of
people
vote for john james okay
he's a great guy but i'm going to
introduce him in a second if biden and
the
democrat socialists are elected they
will dismantle your police departments
dissolve our borders indoctrinate
your children and destroy the suburbs
you know they were talking about
suburban women don't like donald trump i
said i think they do
i think they do
i got rid of a regulation that will
destroy the suburbs i got rid of it i
said ben carson
let's do it ben and we did it nobody
else would do it
and if if biden never got in if he ever
came in it would come back
and you could forget about the suburbs
and one thing i know about suburban
women well i was supposed to do badly
with women the last time remember
at the end they called it that night
they said donald trump
at the beginning they said no he won't
win because he doesn't do well with
women i said
really just tell me about that and then
this guy goes only rosie o'donnell can
you ever
who said that you what are you a
comedian comedians up
so so they said donald trump it will be
a very short evening they were very
happy about that
and then we started winning we won
florida we won
georgia we won south carolina north
carolina we ran
the hall street then we won michigan
right
we won michigan we won wisconsin
you know they were coming we won
pennsylvania anyway at the end of the
realizing it they said you know what
donald trump did great with women
big part of it and that's going to
happen again
because women suburban or otherwise they
want security they want security they
want safety
they want law and order they have to
have law and order and we're going to do
great and i love women and i can't help
it they're the greatest
i love them much more than the men much
more than the men
so i'm saving suburbia i'm getting your
kids
back to school get your kids back to
school
[Applause]
you know we won that big supreme court
case
against your governor so what the hell
happened why isn't it up it's still not
over
you know we sued we won the case one of
the appealing she's appealing the case
hey governor let your state open
get your kids back to school governor
not a good governor
and you know what else i'm also getting
your husbands
they want to get back to work right they
want to get back to work we're getting
your husbands back to work and
everybody wants it and the cure can
never be worse than the problem itself
and let me tell you when she keeps
everybody locked up like a prison
your drugs and alcohol and abuse
and suicide and so many things so many
bad things are happening
she's got to get it back and this goes
for pennsylvania you have a democrat all
democrats
you have a democrat governor goes for
north carolina we're doing great in both
we're winning both of those states
you have a governor in each one and you
have a couple of others look at what's
going on in new york with cuomo it's
horrible it's like a ghost town
and the crime is way up get
the and california has to open up
california has to open up
i mean what are you going to do i see
people today store owners they don't
know what to do
they're going to be arrested if they
open up their little small business they
can't survive
it's a horrible thing that's going on
get your states opened up and this
governor should get
her state opened up
the last administration nearly
extinguished the u.s auto industry from
the job killing it
almost the job-killing trans-pacific
partnership
and i ended it i stopped it to the
horrendous korea trade deal that was a
hillary clinton special
remember she said we will produce 250
000 jobs if we sign this deal and she
was right for south korea they produced
they got him you didn't get them to the
outrageous
fuel economy standards where they're
making it impossible to build a car in
this country
it's outrageous we sued california we
sued a lot of people
because we can build a better car a
safer car
a more important car for a lot less
money
think of that better better looking
safer a little heavier
for a little bit more fuel a little bit
more you're talking about it less
a little bit more fuel and that will
take 10 and 15 and
20 year old versions off you know the
gas guzzlers out of the
overall environmentally it'll be so good
and we're suing california
think of it a better car a safer car
and you'll save three thousand five
hundred dollars a car
and we actually have a lawsuit on this
we're going to build better cheaper
safer and we actually have a lawsuit i
mean it's not even believable
over a little glass of because the
difference between
an engine that works and doesn't work is
a half a glass of
fuel and we have plenty as we've proven
you know we're the number one in the
world
we have plenty of gasoline we have
plenty of gasoline
and it would be great for your car
business and frankly your car business
they ought to get in gear
because they're so afraid of the
environmentalists you know they're so
afraid oh
i don't know i mean they're willing to
spend thousands more to build a car i
say fellas are you sure
there are a couple of them that are very
smart that like what i say i'll tell you
who the smart words are someday
i reversed each and every one of those
obama biden disasters
and now biden wants to reinstate all of
them everything that we've knocked out
in terms of regulations it would take 20
years to build a highway
we have it down to two years to get the
approvals would take 20 years
even longer we have it down to two i
want to get it down to one and it may
get
rejected for environmental or safety
reasons
i want to get it down to one but you
have to see what we've done as a miracle
and that's one of the reasons it's been
so successful i also ended the nafta
nightmare and replaced it with the brand
new
usmca
and the usmca is expected to create tens
of thousands of auto jobs and include
powerful productions to keep your auto
lines going you where do you see what
happens it's just kicking
right now and one of the biggest
beneficiaries will be a state
named michigan
[Music]
and when general motors went bankrupt
biden and obama through the workers of
the
delphi corporation to the wolves anybody
from delphi here
because somebody if you're here you've
got to like trump because we're working
on getting their pensions taken care of
because they were taken advantage of you
know about that
i signed an order to restore the
pensions and healthcare benefits
promised
to workers in wisconsin ohio and
michigan so
they were treated very badly and so were
you i will never let anyone rip off our
great american worker i will not do it
joe biden has made a corrupt bargain
exchange for
his party's nomination he has handed
control of his party over
to the rage-filled socialists marxists
and left-wing extremists if biden wins
the flag-burning radicals on the streets
will be running your government
like in portland the anarchist the
antifa
hey antifa you ever notice they never
want to go after antifa nobody wants to
take on it
they all want to go after anybody but
they don't want
and i keep saying well how are we doing
with antifa
the anarchist this election day you must
stop
the anti-american radicals by delivering
joe biden
and the far left a thundering defeat we
have to make this
you have to get out there on monday
tuesday sunday i don't care today
you have to get out there and vote
you're going to most of you're going to
vote because you believe in voting like
i do i just left
i just voted two days ago i voted i went
to a booth
and they actually asked me sir mayor
please have your identification
but no they and they're right in doing
it i gave her a passport sir do you have
additional identification here's the
time come on what are you doing
you're going to embarrass me here that's
crazy no she was great i mean
i'll tell you what there's no cheating
with that you go to a place
they want identification they want this
you fill out your form they walk you
over to a machine you put it in
i mean these ballots it's turning out to
be exactly what i said right you see
what's going on
who's sending them where are they going
who's sending them back
who's signing them now they want to have
unverified signature one of the
governors wants to have no signature at
all just send it back
what a horrible thing especially since i
see so
you know i watch it so closely this time
when i voted it was so professional
you go in and most of these people the
red wave
generally speaking you go if not tuesday
monday
you know whatever how many people are
going to vote how many people
how many people have already voted
all right good you're sort of a late
state that's good that's good
pennsylvania's are very you know they
just they all vote that last day
but they go they want to go to a polling
booth you're like that
everybody look this is the most
important election in the history of our
country
ever or i wouldn't be standing here like
this every
everybody you got to go out and vote you
got to go out and vote
joe biden is a corrupt politician you've
seen that
he wants to send your jobs to china
while his family rakes in millions of
dollars from the
chinese communist party and other places
the biden wins china wins and by the way
china will own the united states you saw
that clip up there
they will own it china is wonderful
there has never been any one or anything
or any country that has ripped us off
like china we will
win you will win michigan will win
and america will win you got to go and
vote
so we're joined today by some great
warriors
i introduced one but i'll introduce him
again because he's so
important and that's john but
representatives
jack bergman
[Music]
[Applause]
john mullinar
tim wahlberg they're incredible i'll
tell you what they have been with me
right from the beginning great fellas
they
they like you you know they like you
michigan house speaker
lee chatfield lee young guy link
a young guy rnc chairwoman who by the
way
ran my michigan campaign four years ago
ronna mcdaniel
[Music]
she ran it so good that i said when we
won i said you know i have the
person the head of the republican party
i said
i want to get somebody i said you know
what i'll do get me the woman
that won michigan she ran what the hell
is her name her name is okay
her name's rana good she would call me
i'd come
i'd make a speech i'd leave call me the
next day sir you have to come back you
have to come back you have to come back
i said look i'll do it one more time
because you know michigan hadn't been
won like in 36 years
i said look i'll do it one more time
that's it i came back
she said that's it sir don't worry about
it i left two days later i get one more
phone call
sir one more visit and we did you know
michigan was the last
stop that i made
[Music]
i made it in grand rapids michigan
it was one o'clock in the morning
crooked hillary had come in with barack
hussein obama
and they came in together with bill
clinton actually and all of them
and it was unscheduled meaning they
found out they had a problem right it
was unscheduled
they were not they got here at seven
o'clock they had 500 people
i got here at one o'clock in the morning
started speaking at one in the morning
in grand rapids we had 32 000 people
[Music]
and remember it was now okay think of
this
it was now election day so it's now
election day in fact i got home in our
future first lady said to me uh are you
crazy
you know i get up i got home at four in
the morning but
rana did a fantastic job
right congressman are we doing okay are
we winning it
and the great john james is going to win
[Music]
huh
michigan gop chair laura cox is terrific
thank you thank you how are we doing
laura are we up
they said two points that's not enough
we got to get a little more than that
they said two points today the great ted
nugent
dad dad
great he's the only one really dressed
properly
thank you ted very good great job we
appreciate it too
the president of the police officers
association
of michigan jim tiganelli
jim oh he he's like
central casting central cast
candidates for congress some really good
ones paul
young paul young good paul
you're doing well i hear good paul and
the next u.s
senator from the great state of michigan
the legendary john james
i'll tell you he's working so hard just
get it just keep working john
keep working we built the greatest
economy in history
and now we are doing it again we
increase middle class family income over
six
thousand dollars more than five times
again think of this
five times again in all eight years
under the last administration
african-american unemployment hispanic
american unemployment
and asian-american unemployment all
reached their lowest levels
ever recorded think of that what we had
going and we had to close it up and now
we're opening it again to record since
april
we created a record 11.4 million jobs
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations fighting foreign wars
and defending foreign borders but now we
are finally protecting our nation
rebuilding our cities and we are
bringing our
jobs our factories and our troops
back home to the usa
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in the united states
history
that's what we've done it's an amazing
thing what we've done
my opponent's insane immigration plan
would completely eliminate u.s borders
they don't have borders without a border
you don't have a country
by implementing a nationwide catch and
release you catch a criminal
murderer rapist and you release him into
our country
and then he's supposed to come back for
a trial in two years
and we had the argument during the
debate did anybody see the debate the
other night now
quite a debate he would make every
community into a sanctuary city for
violent criminals
my administration is finding the illegal
immigrant
and the criminals gang members the ms-13
killers
and we are either putting them in jail
or sending them
back home and their home has to take
them they didn't use to take them
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars into
the u.s
military much of it spent in michigan
and we have the finest greatest
equipment anywhere in the world we are
the nba
the envy of the world russia china
there's no country we are the envy of
the world the best equipment in the
world
all made in the usa we also passed va
choice
and va accountability we killed the
leader of isis
al-baghdadi
and we took out the world's top
terrorists solomani is dead
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear deal 150 billion 1.8
billion in cash
what a stupid deal and the first call i
get if we win we got to win
first call i get will be from iran
they're going to want to make a deal so
badly because their economy is in
tatters
i recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
and instead of never-ending wars we are
forging peace in the middle east
a vote for republicans is a vote
for the american dream that's what it is
abraham lincoln
abraham lincoln was a republican over
the next four years we will make america
into the manufacturing superpower of the
world this state right here
and we will end our reliance on china
once
and for all we will hire more police
increase penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
[Applause]
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might and we will ensure
peace through strength
our military is now the strongest it's
ever been by far
when i first came in they told me sir we
have no ammunition that's a true story
and no president should ever hear that
again we will end
surprise medical billing require
price transparency already signed
january 1st
lower drug prices even more and we will
always protect
patients with pre-existing conditions
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our school
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great american
flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
[Applause]
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people
of michigan
[Applause]
see now biden would do that and he'd say
for the great people of
how many times did he do that like seven
standing up for the great people of
iowa sir sir it's michigan it's
there's no recovery from that right when
you do that you just walk off the stage
right you can't
i always say the great winston churchill
is a great orator
even if winston churchill did it he
would just walk off the stage
but he didn't do that but sleepy joe
does it a lot
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers
don't let the radicals win get out and
vote
[Applause]
most important election
i believe and i never thought i'd say
this because of what happened four years
ago
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
on november 3rd we must finish the job
and drain the swamp
once and for all we've we've gone a long
way
from midland to mackinac from
pontiac to battle creek great things
and from detroit to right here in
lansing
we stand on the shoulders of michigan
patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this beloved nation
this is the state where henry ford
invented the assembly line think of that
so much
so much has been done in michigan it's
the place where general motors
chrysler and kellogg revolutionized
entire
industries think of that michigan gave
us
motown the mustang and the
unrivaled might of the american
midwest the american witness we got it
all
i think i got every single vote in the
america i like the midwest
we made america into the single greatest
nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet to come that's true
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
[Music]
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on
fighting and we are going to keep on
winning
winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of michigan
we have made america powerful again
our military we have made
america wealthy again
401ks keep them nice and high
i don't want to see you throw them out
these things aren't worth anything
your 401ks are just about at an all-time
high
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you michigan go out
and vote
go out and vote
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can do whatever you feel
[Music]
but you've got to know this
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
someone came up to me and said man
it's fun to stay
[Music]
you can hang out with
[Music]
pick yourself up
[Music]
[Music]
i was down
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
[Music]
smile
[Music]
you must have seen her
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
[Music]
jesus freed
out in the street
and then tickets are forgone
[Music]
turning back
[Music]
is not that bad
[Music]
[Music]
she sings the song
[Music]
the virgin knows
[Music]
when i stand softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you had a today
blue jean baby
[Music]
my
[Music]
you must
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always
[Music]
oh i feel sorry
[Music]
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
count the headlights on the highway
[Music]
today
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
[Music]
him
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
can you feel it coming
[Music]